ouah renaud muselier merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors pas
de déconfinement régionaliser mais
adaptée au territoire sachant votre
région est parmi les moins touchées en
termes de contamination quand on compare
évidemment avec d'autres régions comme
l'ile-de-france où l'alsace est ce que
vous craignez un afflux de vacanciers
porteuses du virus cet été et beaucoup
de questions en question alors hein
nous nous avons toujours demandé un
calendrier une méthode et une approche
différenciée est donc là dedans ce que
nous avons proposé tout à l'heure au
premier ministre avec les dijonnaises
qui l'accompagné nous voulons un seul
code est confiné blanc le même pour tous
avec une intensité qu'ils sont variables
en fonction des territoires
ça veut dire quoi car au national et
après on peut qui sera fixée j'espère
semaine prochaine et on peut rappeler
travailler au niveau local ça veut dire
quoi
effectivement notre région consacre déjà
plutôt moins touchée que tant mieux mais
même dans la région et des disparités
les alpes-de-haute-provence donc pas la
même densité des difficultés que les
bouches-du-rhône où jacques martin on va
donc mettre des barrières elle train
régional ou être un départemental
ça n'a aucun sens par contre nous qui
avons charge les transports
les transports interurbains et les
lycées nous avons la capacité de
réouvrir tout ça en bleu nord est en
bonne voie
parallèlement à ça l'autre volet qui a
été abordé sur le plan de la crise
économique qui catastrophiques sur le
tourisme sur le plan du tourisme
regardez vous avez corse qui sont juste
en face de nous ils sont deux fois deux
puits contaminés que nous est ce qu'on
ne va pas les points on va pas parler on
va échanger avant m
on va couper les ferries autres accords
ses effets et nice toulon marseille
donc ça n'a pas de sens la réalité c'est
que aujourd'hui notre économie est à
plat on a perdu 4 milliards d'euros de
la région provence alpes côte d'azur
dans le mois qui vient d'arriver avec le
yacht et j'amène cantine fermés avec nos
bars hôtels restaurants nous voulons
avoir la doctrine pour la réouverture
des bars à midi aux oies les terrasses
ouvertes et avait par ailleurs
impossible
ou non et on s'adaptera avec une seule
donnée absolument indispensable
c'est la distanciation la distanciation
et se laver les mains
mais ça on s'est organisé il ya colisée
le conflit pas le faire et on va le
faire au niveau régional de façon à
territoire rappelle toi alors autre
information avec cette esquisse de
déconfinement le retour à l'école le 11
mai prochain qui se fera finalement sur
la base du volontariat c'est plus adapté
selon vous à certains parents inquiets
notamment de toute façon maintenant je
retrouver la liberté
il faut retrouver il faut sortir de ce
soir il faut y aller en chargeant ses
habitudes faut-il être parce que je
pense que oui dès que vous êtes à moins
d'un mètre cinquante de quelqu'un est-ce
qu'il faut sauver les bains oui toutes
les heures est-ce que donc les parents
vont laisser tout à fait comme ça on
passait de sérénité les enfants
retournent à l'école même si le conseil
scientifique nous explique que n'y a
aucun risque
il faut apporter des réponses à cette
angoisse permanente qui ont des parents
notamment qui n'ont pas envie de voir
leur progéniture dans un dans une
contamination potentielle et donc j'ai
fait quelques propositions au ministre
monsieur blanc caire pour justement
rassurer ses parents mettre en place un
dispositif qu'ils fassent en sorte que
les personnels éducatifs soient équipés
outils avec masse tous à masquer leur
stratégie
pareil pour les personnels des lycées
qui dépend directement de la région et
qui permet tous les actionnaires et
c'est donc tout ça ça va se mettre en
place petit à laquelle seul objectif il
faut qu'on apporte des solutions aux
multiples questions qui se posent et
qu'elles se passent toujours avec
beaucoup de bon sens de différenciation
et de déconcentration exemple simple
dans les lycées nice est générale à
marseille c'est pas la même chose que
les lycées techniques à manosque
c'est le lycée professionnel dans les
eaux 2 1 n'a absolument rien à voir avec
le lycée polyvalent à tour
vous avez des lycées de 800 places
n'aurait de 12 cents et donc tout ceci
se prêtent façon différente
c'est un avantage peu commun dans la
région pendant sa côte d'azur c'est que
cette année on avait aidé s investit
très lourdement est très fortement où
tous les viscères des plaques des
tablettes numériques lors moins ils ont
pu avoir une continuité éducative
pendant cette heure du conte fièrement
une petite question sur les masques
renault
zié c'est vous même qui avait fait
témoignage de la guerre des masques il
ya quelques semaines sur ce plateau
jérôme c'est le mans annonce 100
millions de masques importés chaque
semaine et qu'on sera en situation un
d'ici le 11 mai de répondre à la demande
vous y croyez des jeux ya beaucoup de
commandes qui sont programmés et donc
coûté aide toi le ciel t'aidera
dans la région provence alpes côte
d'azur après tout les difficultés qu'ont
rencontré les autres présidents de
région dans leurs commandes
nous nous avons mis un pont aérien avec
des commandes qui sont fixes les max des
masques qui ont l'union européenne
validée par le gouvernement chinois pour
quoi évidemment l'exportation qui va se
sent qu'on a les bons de douane pour les
faits rapportés avec ses 20 filiales de
cma-cgm qui est le numéro 1 de l'os des
logiques d'un logistique aux mômes et
qui nous permet de faire un plan de 5
millions de masques par semaine en
région provence alpes côte d'azur en
velin en moins cela ils arriveront pour
les autres on verra plus tard
une réaction peut-être globales sont ces
annonces des manuels macron votre
collègue un des républicains bruno
retailleau chef de file un des sénateurs
les républicains nous disais sur cette
prestation les annonces sur le
déconfinement sont totalement
incompréhensible on se demande pourquoi
le président de la république
s'affranchit de l'arrêt qu'il a lui même
fixé en dévoilant de manière précipitée
et brouillonne une partie du plan dont
il a confié la préparation et la
présentation à son premier ministre vous
seriez aussi sévère envers emmanuel
macron écouté il est resté quatre heures
avec les maires pour les écouter comme
tous ont pu s'exprimer et les grands les
petits les métropoles
au bout de quatre heures peut-être que
le président a voulu leur faire une
petite confidence
bon donc je suis un peu moins sévère en
tout cas ce que j'attends avec
impatience c'est un plan bien coordonné
après toutes ces discussions
la très grosse difficulté du débat c'est
que s'il arrivait qu'un plan tout
bousculer on va lui expliquer qu'il a
concerné les personnes et s'il concerne
on va le dire mais vous êtes le
brouillon donc goûter nous nous avons
fait nos propositions les régions de
france nous sommes 18 région
métropolitaine et outre-mer et nous
parlons
de l'année le voit avec une des
propositions très claires et concrètes
en espérant qu'elle soit parfaitement
intégré dans ce qui sera présenté la
semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup renaud muselier est
président a l'air de la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur et présidents
de régions de france merci à vous